update you on the situation in Ukraine a
short time ago we told you about Air
Raid Sirens sounding across the country
this lunch time with people asked to
take shelter the mayor of Kiev Vitale
Klitschko has issued a message on social
media saying there are explosions in
Kiev stay in shelters
or one of the explosions rang out
between residential buildings in the
solomayan district of the capital all
services follow in place
explosions also took place in the
pasharsk district and hola cvsk
districts there are there is destruction
rather Rescuers and Medics follow to the
places
Let's cross now to our correspondent
usura Elber gear she joins us now live
from Kiev now at yusra did you hear
those Air Raid Sirens can you just give
us a sense of what's happening there
right now
yeah I mean we heard they read sirens in
around 30 to 40 minutes later we heard
the blast there have been 10 blasts
confirmed in Kiev so far and just as we
came out we saw plumes of smoke Rising
above the buildings here in the capital
well this is we're getting reports that
this is widespread south and west of the
country and even two Russian drone
attacks in in the west and this is just
two days after a Mass Attack 69 Rockets
fired into Ukraine from Moscow and this
is New Year's Eve New Year's is the most
celebrated holiday here in Ukraine and
Moscow is sending a very very strong
message
so any indication Israel of the the
damage that's been sustained at this
time
I mean we we're still figuring out how
much damage has been been caused but
that confirmation from the mayor that a
missile that blast was in a residential
area is very concerning people are have
been told to take shelter and and the
attack two days ago which where the
missiles were intercepted coming into
Kiev 16 of the missiles were said to be
intercepted still saw three people
wounded and and two homes destroyed here
so we're yet to see what what will
happen